et depuis le début du confinement la
pression ne cesse de monter dans les
prisons françaises les détenus mais
aussi -et les gardiens ont souvent peur
d'une contamination due à la promiscuité
et la vétusté des bâtiments est les
militants alerte sur les conditions
sanitaires de détention les agents
pénitentiaires ont le sentiment d'être
les oubliés de cette crise sanitaire
un reportage de mona amoudé laure et
nicolas winckler alors que les gars de
kobe 19 se multiplient en prison le
conseil d'état a rejeté de recours
visant à désengorger équipé est les
prisons et les conditions de détention
continue de se dégrader impossible
d'appliquer est les gestes barrières et
de l'autre côté les agents
pénitentiaires craignent le pire un car
il manque de matériel pour travailler
dans de bonnes conditions
by mille détenus ont été libérés pour
désengorger les prisons qui reste en
surpopulation hauteur de 107% contre
119% avant la crise du coc vide
ce n'est pas assez pour françois corbère
juristes et délégué général de
l'association robin des lois qui milite
pour les droits des détenus
il ya beaucoup de personnes détenus en
détention provisoire qui vont sortir de
toute manière dans trois mois dans six
mois qui ne sont pas les personnes
dangereuses sur les ibères avec un
contrôle judiciaire
ils vont bien entendu à l'effet eux être
en confinement comme tout le monde ces
gens là on peut le libérer très
facilement on peut en libérer des mains
d'un seul coup en prison pas de gel et
de masques pour les détenus et les
gestes barrières sont inapplicables
la machine est ce que c'est qu'une
cellule en sachant que vos voisins sont
à même pas 1 mètre de vous et que
n'importe lequel d'entre eux peuvent
contaminer avec le virus l'hygiène dans
la plupart des prisons est détestable
parce que c'est pas que les directs en
prison face à leur boulot ils n'ont pas
les moyens
ils n'ont pas en l'occurrence de savon
le gel de masques donc les personnes
détenues que nous avons au téléphone son
extranet c'est normal après deux recours
rejetée par le conseil d'état
l'association a décidé de saisir la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme et le
comité des droits de l'homme de l'onu
nous relançons fait appel notamment via
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
qu'on a fait il ya quelques jours et le
rhénus le comité des droits de l'homme
de l'onu il ya une procédure d'urgence
on les appelle en iran au secours fait
quelque chose parce qu'il ya des
prisonniers qui vont nourrir
les détenus ne sont pas les seuls
concernés par ces recours rejeté à
fleury mérogis les agents pénitentiaires
voit de plus en plus leurs effectifs
diminuer en raison du virus
là j'ai un collègue voilà qui m'a décrit
ce matin qu'il avait les symptômes c'est
à dire il a une forte fièvre
ils tous beaucoup et il appert il à la
perte du coût des agents qui ne peuvent
pas éviter le contact avec les détenus
en bourse khroubis secrétaire régional
cgt pénitentiaire tire la sonnette
d'alarmé
le personnel est cruellement manque de
matériel au début on nous a pas donné de
masse au début aussi on a eu des
problèmes pour avoir ne serait-ce que le
minimum quand je parle d'un minimum
c'est les gels hydroalcooliques jeu pas
de minimum c'est des lingettes on avait
du mal à avoir ça et dans la détention
où je ne veux pas là en ile de france il
ya un code de détention où on n'a pas ça
il y avait 86 cas avérés dans cette
prison à fleury mérogis tu 86 cas mais
ça touche du surveillant au directeur
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
le personnel est le sentiment de ne pas
être écoutés on nous oublié personne ne
parle de nous alors qu'il ya des mots
alors qu'il ya des souffrances alors
qu'il ya des agressions et ça continue
personne de nous n'est en sécurité parce
que l'extérieur on respire
mais dans la prison on est confiné et
c'est très dur
selon nicole belloubet la garde des
sceaux plus de deux cent mille masques
de protection ont été distribués au sein
de l'administration pénitentiaire des
mesures encore insuffisantes pour les
représentants syndicaux